[Music]
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
[Music]
it's been three years since audiences
first saw gal gadot's wonder woman light
up the big screen
and soon enough she'll be back stronger
than ever immersed in a time of vibrant
neon lights and seriously nostalgic 80s
tunes
and because wonder woman's success broke
a handful of records like the biggest
grossing live-action film ever
directed by a woman the bar for the
sequel is set high for fans and critics
alike
here's everything you need to know
before you watch
when we first meet diana in 2017's
wonder woman she's princess of the
amazons trained to be an unconquerable
warrior
once she meets an american pilot who
tells her about the massive conflict
that's raging in the outside world
she leaves home for the first time
believing she can stop the threat
we last see her fighting alongside men
in world war 1 and she finally discovers
her full powers and true destiny
so where exactly will wonder woman be in
this film diana prince aka wonder woman
will be in washington dc
in the 80s continuing to save the world
while in the shadows
during the day she works in cultural
archaeology and anthropology at the
smithsonian museum of natural history
and by night she's a gal on the go and
although she has an apartment with very
little in it
she doesn't get home that much producer
chuck robin says
you're gonna see an expansion of her
abilities as wonder woman now she's been
seasoned because she's been doing what
she's been doing since the end of world
war 1 to 1984.
it's plenty of time for her to expand
her powers and yet she's always learning
now if you're wondering why the film
takes place in such a specific year
it's because 1984 is a nostalgic blast
from the past
that will allow the franchise to play
with other themes about society
perhaps in a more colorful and playful
way than the first film
and although fans saw his heartbreaking
demise in wonder woman
steve is in fact back and yes he's
actually the same steve trevor played by
chris pine although the how and why of
his return
are being kept under wraps by the film's
cast and crew
apparently director patty jenkins has
had this surprise up her sleeve for a
while
and his character will be intrinsic to
the story gadot even teased the
rekindling of steven diana's romance
saying
in this one they meet each other again
but it's more the adulthood part of it
i think it's even more romantic and more
sexy and lustful
she's been waiting for him you know it's
been 80 years since they last met and
she hadn't loved anyone else since
pedro pascal plays this scheming
character max lord
lord is the president of black gold
international seemingly selling people
their biggest dreams of power wealth and
success
via infomercials kristen wiig also stars
as barbara minerva a gemologist who
works at the museum with diana
she's funny awkward shy and brilliant
and dons glasses
and oversized clothing she befriends
diana before falling prey to black gold
international scheme and the idea that
she can have everything her heart yearns
for
she undergoes a wild transformation to
become the cheetah but whether or not
she can actually handle her new powers
remains to be seen actresses robin
wright and connie nielsen are also
confirmed to reprise their roles as
antiope and hippolyta respectively
while the film explores what happens
when people get rewarded in
excess especially in a heightened time
like the 80s audiences in 2020 will see
a lot of parallels to our current world
whether the 80s or
current day the film will hold a mirror
to society and allow people to reflect
on what they think will make them happy
versus what actually will and with a bar
set so high the dynamic explosive
colorful big time action will likely
meet fans expectations
the film will mix comedy drama action
and adventure
and the aesthetic will capture the
height of the world in the 80s
so now you know and now you can go watch
wonder woman 1984
on december 25th
you